boa noite
eu queria nem se essa palestra com uma
pergunta que tipo de cabelo
vocês gostariam de ter
amor solidariedade e atitude
foram essas três ações que fizeram uma
amiga minha e do cabelo dela para uma
paciente do hospital que ela trabalhava
essa paciente estava passando pelo
tratamento quimioterápico e todos os
funcionários dos hospitais se comoveram
que ela ficou muito triste com a queda
dos cabelos dela eles fizeram queriam
fazer uma vaquinha para comprar uma
peruca
bom eles viram o quão caro é uma peruca
então eles decidiram correr atrás de
alguém que fizesse as perucas pra eles
eles conseguiram costureiro que falou eu
faço pelo que é de graça não tem
problema nenhum mas eu preciso do
material que é o cabelo e aí a amiga
sem pensar duas vezes cortou o cabelo
dela e eles conseguiram fazer essa
peruca para essa paciente
bom ela tinha um cabelo que passava da
cintura e do nada apareceu o cabelo
curtinho que aconteceu todo mundo
perguntou ela explicou que aconteceu e e
eu a milene todas as amigas dela
decidimos fazer a mesma atitude que ela
em cortar os cabelos
eu ia milene cortamos os cabelos outras
amigas também mas a gente encontra uma
dificuldade muito grande de achar um
lugar que a gente pudesse entregar esses
cabelos é então uma conversa em outubro
de 2013
a gente decidiu criar a campanha
cabeleireira o que a gente vai fazer a
gente ia pegar esses cabelos arrecadados
de amigos e amigos de amigos e levar
para hospitais ou instituições que
fizessem esse trabalho com crianças e
pacientes com câncer
essa confecção ea ficar por parte da
instituição
a alegria não ia fazer isso a gente só
irá destinar esses cabelos nos hospitais
e para as instituições
então a gente começou a divulgar isso na
internet
claro as pessoas começaram a cortar e
postar a foto
a gente achou que só essa doação podia
precisava ter algum
a gente precisava agradecer às pessoas
que estavam no cabelo pra gente então a
gente decidiu fazer um certificado e
deve ser indicado por essas pessoas o
que tornou quase um viral porque as
pessoas doavam cabelo e passava a foto
do cabelo junto com certificado
isso começou a bombar a gente começar a
gente teve um aumento de doações muito
grande
só que com isso vieram as cobranças
muitas pessoas perguntavam qual destino
final dos cabelos o que vocês vão fazer
muitas pessoas não acreditavam que a
gente ia levar para as instituições
esses cabelos
então a gente chegou num ponto que a
gente teve que decidir qual caminho que
o cabeleireiro ea seguir
eu vou continuar falando da pessoal e/ou
gente continuava a arrecadar esses
cabelos e pegava todo o processo desde a
confecção até entrega dessas perucas ou
a gente parava a partir daí e dar um
destino para essas doações nesse cabelos
que a gente já tinha bom porque não
tentar
vamos tentar só que não estava nos
alcança eu não sabia confeccionar peruca
muito menos a milene
então a gente precisando de alguma
cultura e confeccionar suas perucas com
a gente vamos correr atrás de parceiros
para a sua confecção
a gente conseguiu marcar uma reunião com
o salão andré lopes que com uma mãe
acolhe um filho a andré lopes acolher o
cabeleireiro e ele não seria nada se não
fosse essa essas duas mulheres que andré
ea fab
logo em dezembro a gente começou em
outubro
em dezembro a gente falou com ela e ela
tocou de primeira e o cabeleireiro não
tinha dinheiro o cabeleireiro não tinha
nada ela falou vocês não precisam se
preocupar com o dinheiro eu dou material
das da confecção das perucas para vocês
e faça sua confecção
em dezembro a gente conseguiu fazer a
primeira entrega do cabeleireiro que foi
paraná julho em santa rosa de viterbo
assim 270 quilômetros de são paulo
era uma prima de uma amiga nossa e uma
pessoa muito especial pra gente como
todo o cabelo alegria era muito novo pra
mim para milene
a gente sente uma vontade enorme de
compartilhar com os nossos amigos e
familiares
esse momento que essa entrega da
primeira peruca porque a gente estava
eufórica
então a gente decidiu filmar essa
entrega
bom a gente não só compartilhar com os
amigos e os familiares mas a gente
compartilha também do nosso facebook
eu acho que as pessoas gostaram tanto
que elas se sentiram tão colhidas com o
vídeo que a gente gostou porque ele é
tão louco pra gente para as pessoas
também é então era demais porque as
pessoas compartilhavam falavam tenho
certeza que meu cabelo também essa
peruca e que essa menina está excedendo
um pouquinho da minha felicidade
então é muito lindo cada entrega que a
gente fazia ver a reação das pessoas
compartilhando aqui e as pessoas tinham
certeza que realmente o cabelo delas que
estavam naquela peruca e em dois anos o
cabeleireiro uma proporção tão grande
que graças a deus a gente hoje não tenho
só criança a gente atende mulheres
também tratamento do brasil inteiro e
agora vou contar pra vocês um pouquinho
das conquistas que a gente teve nesses
dois anos
a gente já passou dos 65 mil doações de
cabelo é muita coisa a gente recebe
doação de cabelo
a gente recebe doação de cabelo do mundo
inteiro e não é brincadeira é de todos
os países a gente já recebeu doação de
cabelo
a gente já chegou quase 300 mil likes no
facebook 45 mil leques no instagram já
passou em 90 revistas jornais sites e
blogs e já deu mais de 20 entrevistas
fotos letras televisões
agora os dados mais importantes de toda
alegria claro a gente atendeu mais de
150 crianças mais de 50 mulheres ea
gente já fez mais de 60 doações de
perucas para hospitais ou caso de apoio
e hoje é um dia especial estou muito
feliz e as pessoas não sabe que o
cabeleireiro vai aumentar esse número e
vai fazer a doação de 40 perucas para
onde vou lá que aqui do rio
então hoje a cabeleireira aumentando
esse número é com muita felicidade que a
gente aumentar esse número para 100 hoje
agora vou contar pra vocês um pouquinho
do impacto que o cabeleireiro tem na
vida dos pacientes
eu não vou comentar todo está porque
senão vou ficar falando até amanhã eu
tenho tempo então eu vou falar só de
alguns pra vocês sentirem um pouquinho
do que a gente sente quando a gente
entrega as perucas tem muitas perucas
que a gente entregue que nem parece que
são perucas
então tem o caso da manga ela já é
adulta já tem o caso de bibi
todos sempre muito especiais pra gente
vou falar agora eu quero contar o caso
da raça é um caso especial pra gente
porque no dia que a gente vai fazer a
entrega foi tudo lindo a gente chegou na
casa dela em campinas
entregamos a peruca ela ficou com
vergonha de colocar a peruca na nossa
frente então ela saiu e foi por no
quarto junto com a tia quando ela saiu
da sala a mãe da garrafa começou a
chorar muito e eu e milena a gente vai
acolher a mãe da menina contou para
gente que quando uma semana antes a rafa
tinha entrado no quarto dela se trancado
e tinha curta rasgado todas as fotos de
quando ela tinha cabelo ea mãe dela
perguntou por que ela tinha feito isso e
ela disse que ela não via mais um porque
vê aquelas fotos porque ela não era mais
aquele jeito e se emocionou muita gente
é na hora que rafa chegou a gente logo
tentou parar de chorar para rafa não vê
que a gente estava chorando e participar
daquela felicidade com a raiva porque é
um momento de felicidade e até ela
brincou no vídeo tem um vídeo dela ela
brinca a gente rafa conta que você
gostou dela brincando vocês 100% elenco
então tinha então isso essas atitudes
que as crianças têm que mostram pra
gente que a gente realmente seguir o
caminho certa essas duas pequenininhas
ela tinha 13 anos quando a gente
entregou pergunta pra elas são muito
poucas
aí eu quero falar que a cabeleireira não
atende só pacientes com câncer
a maria eduarda tem alopécia que é uma
doença que não nasce pelo nenhum no
corpo e as marias
a gente brinca são duas irmãs gêmeas ela
tem uma doença chamada epiderme bolhosa
que é uma doença de hipersensibilidade
na pele e faz com que o cabelo não nasça
então a gente também fez a doação de
branquinha pra ela
agora vou contar um pouquinho da dae do
ar
quando a gente chegou no hospital gente
vocês precisam ver jeito que essa menina
recebeu a gente ela contava piada e
cantava luan santana e andava pra lá e
pra cá e brincava com todos os aparelhos
do hospital
só que eu não quero contar pra vocês
como é que foi entrega porque eu quero
que ela conte como que foi receber a
biruta rave
nenê ainda trazia o nervoso gente ela
não é assim um mau taxa deixa ela fala
três horas aqui vamos lá que você quer
falar como é que foi pra você ganhar um
pouquinho quando a gente entregou pra
você quase dois anos atrás eu eu fiquei
muito feliz quando ela chegar eu fiquei
feliz que tinha por que é que não podem
pedir porque as vier o plantio nem nunca
viemos com ela puxa o seu cabelo fiquei
muito feliz
aí eu coloquei que não aceita ela de
gargan no dia todas as noites gaga
kennedy ela saiu do hospital dançando
lady gaga pra todo mundo agora se você
tivesse entregue essa daqui rosa ela ia
ficar mais ainda né tá chorando pela
linda e agora pessoal queria voltar
na primeira pergunta que eu fiz pra
vocês no começo da palestra que tipo de
cabelo
vocês gostariam de ter
é o cabeleireiro nasceu eu quero eu
durante a palestra eu troquei de perigo
algumas vezes porque eu quero mostrar
pra vocês
o porquê que alegria nasceu alegria
nasceu e o nosso a nossa missão é poder
levar sorrisos autoestima a pacientes
com câncer através das perucas
a gente não quer que o cabelo a queda do
cabelo seja um problema durante o
tratamento
a gente quer que seja uma brincadeira e
realmente se o paciente hoje quiser uma
peruca de dredd se o estilo dele é ter
uma peruca de dredd ele vai ter uma
peruca de dredd se amanhã ele quiser ter
uma peruca rosa e guarda eduarda ele vai
ter uma peruca rosa e se depois de
amanhã ele quiser uma peruca de dread e
rosa ele vai ter uma peruca de dredd
rosa e eu queria finalizar essa palestra
com o pensamento quando a gente é
criança
a gente aprende nos filmes e nos
desenhos a separar as pessoas entre os
vilões e os mocinhos
só que a gente sabe que isso não é
verdade hoje é muito difícil você
conseguir separar essas pessoas dentre
esses dois pólos porque são as pessoas
normais são as pessoas reais a gente
erra hoje e amanhã a gente acerta a
gente tem idéias
a gente tem pensamentos positivos e
negativos
às vezes esses pensamentos positivos na
sim
idéias só que as idéias se perdem ao
esbarrar em duas perguntas por que e
para quê
nem sei falar pra vocês quantas vezes já
perguntaram pra mim porque eu faço tudo
isso
oprah que eu faço tudo isso por que eu
gasto meu tempo sem ganhar nada fazendo
esse trabalho ou pra que eu tenho tanta
dor de cabeça com esse trabalho sem
ganhar nada e eu queria falar pra vocês
que a alegria não ele se move com outra
pergunta como fazer a alegria nasceu a
partir desta pergunta como fazer para
mudar a vida desses pacientes como que a
gente pode fazer pra mudar o mundo e se
lá atrás quando a gente teve que
escolher o caminho que a gente
conseguisse se a gente não fosse na
pergunta de como fazer para mudar o
mundo hoje com alegria só ia ser uma
idéia e eu não estava vivendo tudo que
estou vivendo hoje ele está conseguindo
fazer essas crianças viverem tudo o que
elas exibem hoje